was geht hier soll max und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem video wir spielen
heute ist lisa punkte oder stereo das
ist so ähnlich wie addario und erstmal
müssen wir zum coolen namen geben dann
erklärt worum es geht ok leighton anfang
wir starten einfach durch es geht
hierbei darum dass wir möglichst viele
von diesen pünktchen aus sammelt und
anderen spielern reinfährt so wie ich
das gerade eben gemacht habe man darf
nicht frontal in eine andere wurst in
einen anderen bus rein fahren sonst
platzt mann und die punkte die man
aufgegessen hat landen alle auf der
karte und es geht ganz einfach dabei
darum dass man möglichst groß wird dass
ein ja schon das ganze spielprinzip den
typen schnappen wir uns und ich finde es
das mega lustig war es nicht also
grafisch designtechnisch definitiv cool
als cabrio insgesamt weiß ich nicht
genau was ich cool finden soll habe ich
jetzt auch nicht länger nicht mehr
gespielt so zac den großen typen uns
auch direkt wird ich habe schon gesehen
lukas gespielt judiths gespielt und
damit hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon
irgendwann mal gespielt mir zuerst jede
menge spaß gemacht als ich mal so an
gezockt habe nicht ablaufen abstammt
effekt es gibt hier relativ cool
taktiken
ich kenne nicht allzu viel ich will das
nicht so lange und man stirbt einfach
das ist eine super taktik den riesen
typen haben uns geholt
was sagen wollte es gibt hier relativ
cool taktiken mit dem man ja sage ich
mal erfolgreich sein kann eine davon ist
dass man die gegner wie eine echte
schlange und kreis deshalb ist mit
echten schlange zu tun
ich werde einfach probieren bisschen
größer zu werden und dann zeige ich euch
einfach mal hier wachsen und wachsen es
ist sehr vernünftig
nice nice nice okay vielleicht kann ich
euch jetzt schon zeigen wenn ihr einer
jetzt rein fährt und sich das zeug zu
holen es hat mir ganz knapp meinen
taktik bei mir läuft gerade gut ich habe
echt wie glück irgendwie alle um mich
herum schaffen irgendwie ab ohne dass
ich großartig was dazu beitrage brand
die sterberate von selbst erworbenen
überhaupt keine tricks für neues wir
sind auf platz sieben global label heiße
ich ja und stadt birgt zeigt die taktik
geht es nun zu null bei dem kleinen
typen aber man nimmt jemand in seine
mitte und fährt dann einfach immer
engere kreise und dann irgendwann
erwischt man den anderen und kann sich
so auch relativ große gegner verknüpfen
also selbst wenn gegners größer wäre als
ich selbst dann könnt ihr einfach um ihn
herum fahren und ihn so quasi einsperren
und an dem kreis immer verkleinern bis
er irgendwann sterben wird
ich werde ein riesiger unterscheiden
du wirst gefahren mein freund oder auch
nicht ich glaube wir brauchen den
cooleren neuen namen machen mal was
politisches das passt doch der
regenbogen und never trump sehr gut wir
machen jetzt amok im spiel so richtig
aggressiv mal und holen sie direkt am
anfang alle gegner und probieren somit
einen erfolgreichen start hinzulegen der
typ macht die heiße wurst taktik und da
bin ich schon tot
sehr erfolgreich oder handelt jetzt auch
sony ich schreibt sind die kommentare
ich wollte euch noch mal die kugel
taktik zeigen verdammt auch nein danke
dir kollege schweren kann ich mich bei
so was natürlich nicht und die schlange
wächst und wächst
wir kommen mit den schaffen wir das
jetzt bitte mal ist es immer so knapp
ich denke immer okay die anderen
brauchen bestimmen eine sekunde bis sie
anfangen selbst speed zu geben aber tun
sie nicht und dann kriegen die mich doch
ich will einmal auf platz eins sein und
für einmal auch euch zeigen wie diese
coole taktik funktioniert bevor mir
dafür dem codenamen so muss es klappen
wir sind die maut schlange niemand kann
uns aufhalten auch du nicht groß aber
wir nehmen uns jedenfalls ist und bis
doch eigentlich das ein witz kann man
schon sagen sag du kommst du wirst mir
was kleiner virtuell einfach gesagt man
gegen das dich dann bis zu ernst und
diesem typen werde ich jetzt einsperren
den werde ich jetzt so was von
einsperren falls nein das ist ich mich
anstellen müssen relativ schlauer
bursche das was von mir das war's von
hier
okay wir werden es schaffen aggressiv
unberechenbar smatch.com stand kaum
schneller 1 abstauben abstauben dass das
neue als ob wenn ein fachmann so richtig
klein ist und vor den augen einfach so
ein riesiger haufen wo diese coolen
leuchte zeug auftaucht und du einfach
den können kannst du dir so denkt womit
das leben kennt ihr das könnt ihr im
moment wahrscheinlich nicht vor ich
möchte mein herz und
und als stück auch noch selbst leute
guckt er macht diese coole taktik die
ich euch zeigen will
irgendwie ist ja auch nicht so ein
geheimtipp aber was sollte kentucky
würde sagen es macht mehr spaß als mario
okay ich glaube gerade wollte mich ein
spielen wollte er wahrscheinlich auch
aber kuba und werde mich jetzt ein
sprecher von lustig als lang doch gar
nicht eine schlange lang doch gar nicht
du kannst mich so nicht einstellen diese
amateure wie man dieses faktors die
denken hier schlange war lang genug an
muster witze drüber matip ist froh ist
also und was man vielleicht tag gegönnt
nummer eins zack nummer zwei kopf an
kopf tack nummer drei nummer vier
ich habe einen eingesperrt und man auch
machen dies mehr als leicht hoch weil
vorsichtig sein
besser was war das der riesentyp ist
gefragt der riesige riesentyp der
allerwichtigste alle riesen typen nummer
6 oder sowas marge auf platz sechs ob
das die runde der runden werden kann
der riesen der riesige riesen riesentyp
ist einfach geplatzt
direkt unter mir wo leute das könnte
series werden
das könnte series werden der typ ist
einfach die sie eingesperrt wird die
gott sei dank aber erst auch so kaputt
gegangen sollte es wird immer besser wir
wachsen wachsen wachsen auf platz vier
alle beide gefragten noch bevor ich
meine taktik anwenden konnte aber leute
wir wachsen und wachsen
ich selbst gestorben ist gestorben da
können wir etwas können von dem von dem
riesen ach nein
es ist so schlimm sie holen sich alles
was wie ich finde eigentlich mir zusteht
meine sache wird schrecklich sein
ja ja gleich fünf minuten ja ok ich muss
meine schwester abholen es trifft mich
so wenig von platz eins komm schon heute
tut so weh tut verdammt weh jetzt
aufhören zu müssen
nein kein platz eins irgendwie sterben
dass ich noch irgendwie gewinne geht es
lohnt sich auf jeden fall sich den typen
zu knacken ist fehlt so wenig kooperativ
oder schafft es okay das war's